what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with the war of jokes and
riddles right around the corner what
this does is it actually gives us a
chance to come back and cover stories
that we really never would have covered
before just because we didn't really
have a reason to you but this is
basically the first story arc of
something called Batman zero year but
this is all basically leading into the
war of jokes and riddles and that brings
in the nature of that story contrary to
what you might think the war of jokes
and riddles is not a continuation of
Batman rebirth instead it's what's
called a red card which stands for
retroactive continuity now a retcon is
what a writer comes back and they either
modify something that happened before or
they add in something new that was never
there before
now retcons can be good they can be bad
some people love them some people hate
them whatever the case may be different
people have responded to a different
ways and a lot of it depends on how it's
done and whether or not it changes the
characters you know that they're used to
because a lot of comic fans just don't
like change but with regards to the war
of jokes and riddles that's what that is
it's a red card it's a writer coming
back after the origin story of Batman
was done and then adding information to
it now with regards to zero year this
was actually a year long story
what DC did following the events of the
new 52 is they came back and they
launched something called zero month and
zero month was just designed for the
purpose of issuing zero issues for like
characters and teams and so on and it
basically just focused on their origin
stories you know with that man because
he was so popular you can just do a zero
issue instead whether Scott Schneider
was given leave to basically write this
great big huge a year long story that
told the events of how it was that Bruce
Wayne became Batman now for the most
part the origin story is pretty
consistent it's one of those timeless
things Bruce Wayne is walking out of a
theater with his parents they're shot in
an alley by Joe Chill he ends up
becoming Batman that's that but what
this does is it actually brings in the
equation of the Joker and the Riddler
and that's why this is so important is
because the war of jokes and riddles is
basically part four of this three-part
story Batman zero years so with regards
to this what it does is it initially
picks up with the Red Hood and this is
kind of a cool concept because the Red
Hood is basically the identity of the
Joker before he became the Joker and now
this concept of the Red Hood is not new
and it actually predates jason todd by
years and years and years the Red Hood
concept dates all the way back to
Detective Comics issue number 106
in 1951 with a story called the man
behind the Red Hood and he was basically
DC's first real attempt to offer some
measure of an explanation of who the
Joker was before he became the Joker the
issue with this is that it was really
just kind of a one-off there really
wasn't a whole lot done with it it
really wasn't until the Killing Joke
that DC really went through and actually
offered a tried and true origin and
that's one of the reasons why the
Killing Joke is considered to be one of
the most important stories in the
history of the Joker and really Batman's
continuity because it offers the most I
guess really the largest and best
explanation of the Joker's origin now
The Killing Joke is a story I believe we
did videos on that you'll find those
down in the description but the fact
remains that in terms of this particular
story the Red Hood is basically just the
identity of a guy and we don't know who
he is and so much like the original
Killing Joke story we never really got
the exact name of that guy or at least
you know never really were definitively
told who he was instead it was just
here's a possible origin of the Joker
and even then within the confines of the
story it wasn't guaranteed but the fact
your name but the arrival of the Red
Hood here really coincides with the
emergence of Batman as a vigilante but
at this point in his characters history
that is to say when he was first
becoming Batman he hadn't become Batman
yet instead Bruce Wayne had just
returned to Gotham after going through
all of his years of training and
effectively was fighting crime in the
city of Gotham trying to return into a
state of normalcy
now the first idea is to focus on who
the Red Hood is and what we end up
finding out is that this Red Hood
character is basically a guy who's going
through and just rallying up all these
different crime groups all these
different criminals that exist within
the realm of Gotham now in terms of how
he does this in terms of how it all
works this is not information that's
readily given to us and that's one of
the reasons why Scott Snyder's Batman
was written so well is because you
basically learned about things
it's Batman learned about them it's not
as though you got this great big huge
premutation that told you everything you
needed to know and then you basically
just watch that man as you tried to
uncover it it was basically you trying
to solve this mystery at the same time
as him and so what is it happening here
is there's actually a really cool
discussion between Batman and Alfred
because remember this is all still
relatively new
there's no Batcave at the moment but
from the perception of Alfred is really
more about keeping Bruce Wayne safe more
so than letting him become Batman
because remember for Alfred
pennyworth he was a huge part of the
Wayne family he had basically crazed
Bruce Wayne ever since he was a little
kid or at the very least had a major
role in in terms of what it was that he
did and how it all came together that
with regards to Alfred's perception of
this he's actually not on board and
that's kind of a funny scenario to look
at this because Alfred again it's so
important as part of the Batman mythos
he contributes in a lot of different
ways and so the fact that he was not
really readily on board with this is
just a testament to the fact that his
loyalty is to Bruce Wayne not
necessarily to the city of Gotham and so
what this does is it coincides with the
arrival of a guy named uncle Philip for
those of you guys who are not really
familiar with Batman the new 52 was
basically a reboot and to talk about
this for a second there's a difference
between a reboot and a relaunch a
relaunch is basically just kind of
refreshing things kind of changing
things up a little bit shuffling things
around but for the most part the past of
all the characters are still intact with
a reboot like what DC did in the new 52
what they basically did is they sat down
to you as the reader and they said okay
we want you to pretend as if Batman has
never existed as if we basically written
him for the very first time now it's a
very difficult thing to do just because
of the fact that there's so much history
there especially for those who have been
reading Batman all that time but it was
basically designed for new people if
you'd never read about man's story in
your life you only knew of him it was
designed for you to basically sit down
and say okay this characters never been
written before and so everything that
I'm seeing is basically being told for
the very first time how those stories
unfolded is a whole nother beast but the
idea of uncle Phillip being brought in
here is that Phillip has actually got
named Phillip Kane and he's basically
the uncle of Bruce Wayne so the result
is that where Bruce had effectively just
left Gotham City essentially after his
parents were killed once he got to an
age where he could go around and train
himself to become a very skilled
vigilante Phillip Kane basically took
over Wayne Enterprises and the idea was
that he had actually declared Bruce
Wayne dead now this was not coming from
a place of like being evil right like
Phillip came to not do it because he
wanted to be a bad guy he simply did it
because of the fact that it seemed like
the right thing to do
somebody had to keep the legacy of the
Wayne's going more so than that
Phillip Kane really wanted Bruce to just
kind of be able to have a pretty regular
life you want them to be able to go on
and live life as best he can but
with the return of Bruce Wayne it's now
obvious that that's going to be
impossible that Bruce Wayne is going to
want to have a role in Wayne Enterprises
largely because of the fact that he's
the heir to the Wayne family and so he's
the one person that legally has standing
and the ability to involve himself in
the company now the faculty has been
declared dead it makes things a little
complicated but he's very much alive and
so it's not like he can't prove the fact
that he is alive we would just kind of
go through some legal mumbo-jumbo and
different things like that but you know
it's not really one of these things
where Phillip wants to stand in his way
and it seems as though he wants to make
life a bit easier for Bruce Wayne now
the other half of this comes with
Phillip Kane himself and what we learn
is that when Phillip had essentially
taken up the role of running Wayne
Enterprises that he had also brought
along a guy by the name of Edward nygma
now of course we know Edward nygma to be
the Riddler eventually he becomes the
Riddler but at this point in the story
he hasn't become that character yet
instead he's really more of an advisor
for Phillip Kane now the backstory to
this is that there isn't one there's no
story explaining the life and times of
Edward nygma all we really know is that
he was just a guy who worked at Wayne
Enterprises and caught the attention of
Phillip Kane but the idea is that he
served as a kind of advisor a guide to
would basically give Phillip Kane the
best direction to go in for the
betterment of the company the difference
here is that with Bruce Wayne having
returned the perception that Edward
nygma offers here is that Bruce Wayne is
not going to go quietly Bruce Wayne is
not going to simply just walk away and
when that time comes
Phillip Kane is going to be faced with a
tough choice is he going to let it
happen or is he going to fight it to to
nail the problem with this is that
Phillip Kane has no legal standing to
actually run Wayne Enterprises and keep
it for himself and so that's the
predicament that's the situation that
Edward nygma offers the only real option
Phillip Kane has here is to basically
kill his nephew and so again it's really
kind of a crazy scenario because now it
offers this position whereby Bruce Wayne
is you know besieged by the criminal
element within Gotham as well as what
seems to be his own family now things
get a little more complicated and the
waters get a little more muddled when
we're introduced with what seems to be
cause water Cobblepot and the return of
the Red Hood in the sense that the Red
Hood basically been acquiring Wayne
Enterprise weapons now again this is
kind of a crazy situation because the
question has to be asked how did he get
ahold of these but the other half of
this is trying to find a way to figure
out who Red Hood is because remember
when Bruce Wayne had basically taken his
DNA and
basically didn't find any evidence that
the Red Hood existed on any database
whatsoever he's basically a ghost no one
knows who he is no one knows where he
comes from or anything like that he's
just there this combined with all these
different henchmen make him a pretty
dangerous person now the other half of
this is that Oswald Cobblepot is
actually Bruce Wayne and this is
designed to do a couple of things the
first is to show us how intelligent the
Red Hood is in the sense the Red Hood
was able to easily deduce that Oswald
Cobblepot is actually the vigilante they
don't really know him by name but the
other half of this is that it also shows
how clumsy Batman is in this particular
scenario because remember vs. still
learning how to be a superhero and so
the result is that he's trying to figure
things out as best he can but him
becoming the detective that we've
learned to enjoy in terms of his own
stories that guy hasn't emerged yet it's
kind of cool here because really all he
can do is in this scenario is just run
because he's basically in a blimp a few
hundred feet above the air and he really
has nowhere to go and so all I can do is
really just run now of course with the
technology and the money that that he
and Alfred have there's different
devices he can use to engineer his own
escape but we're treating back to their
brownstone back to work Alfred's at the
scenario plays out the exact same way
it's basically just Bruce Wayne talking
to Alfred and saying this guy doesn't
exist anywhere like I have no idea who
this guy is I have no idea where this
guy comes from there's no information on
him and that's what makes the Red Hood
so difficult to pin down because if he
had a database there was a name there
somewhere they could start from there
and try to track this guy's life down
for the guys who ghost there's nothing
about him anywhere now the other half of
this is also the difficult situation
that Bruce Wayne and Alfred are in where
we might look at Bruce and Alfred and
see them as very much father and son in
the sense that Alfred's the closest
thing Bruce Wayne has to a dad but he
would get along perfectly well instead
it was very tumultuous in the beginning
it's very much the idea of Bruce Wayne
basically saying look I'm trying to do
something here in Gotham I'm trying to
make this city a better place what have
you ever done what contribution have you
ever made to the world well of course
this is a huge insult to Alfred not
really because of the fact that Bruce
Wayne is calling about insight you've
never done anything useful with your
life Alfred has but it's also because of
the fact that Alfred has been there
every single step of the way and so
again it makes for a very tumultuous
situation because at this moment right
now Alfred is not the guy that Bruce
Wayne regularly can
and they just simply haven't built that
up yet Bruce Wayne has been gone for
years and years building up his own
skills honing his own abilities and so
for him Phillip Kane basically
represents the last vestige of family
that he has left and so following this
argument between himself and Alfred he
basically goes to visit Phil okay and of
course calls him up says hey look we
need to talk only for him to arrive on
the scene and basically be greeted with
this massive celebration about him
returning home now of course with this
being held at a museum of sorts and with
us knowing the Bruce Wayne is not really
one for Hardy's different things like
that he effectively sneaks out now of
course this leads him to encountering
Edward nygma for the very first time and
that's one of the cool things about this
is because Edward nygma despite just
being a regular guy it's one of the most
dangerous men out there and the reason
why I say that is because not all
villains who are dangerous have
incredible powers not all villains who
are dangerous have super speed and
strength and agility and different
things like that sometimes they're smart
enough to deceive you that's why Edward
nygma is so cool is because he doesn't
have any powers to speak of but he's one
of the smartest men out there when it
comes to tricking people into riddles
messing with people's minds and so again
with him encountering Bruce Wayne what
he basically does is he spills the beans
on Phillip Caine and says Phillip Caine
is giving weapons to them now who they
are Bruce Wayne doesn't know and Edward
nygma doesn't tell him but is basically
sending Bruce Wayne on a suicide mission
because remember Edward nygma is not
doing this because he genuinely believes
that Bruce Wayne is a good guy because
he genuinely likes him because he
genuinely cares it's because he wants
them out of the picture but by painting
his picture and revealing this
information about Phillip Caine it in
turn will send Bruce Wayne after not
only Phillip Caine but the people that
Phillips working with and so the idea is
to basically just get Bruce Wayne killed
that's really just the goal here of
course we know that the people that
Edward Gein was referring to is the Red
Hood gang but again it's kind of a crazy
scenario because Edward nygma in turn
tips off the Red Hood about where it is
a Bruce Wayne's going and so once Bruce
Wayne returns back to his home we
ultimately have the Red Hood gang
sending themselves on him just because
of the fact that Red Hood one is like
look you know I was never invited to
this party and you know that kind of a
thing and it creates kind of a weird
situation and so what this does is mimic
almost perfectly the events of death in
the family now the reason why I say that
is because Scott Snyder wrote a story
called death of the family but it
well established within these regular
interviews and different things like
that that writer Scott Schneider at the
time loved a lot of the old-school
Batman mythos he had educated himself
quite heavily when it came to the
character of Bruce Wayne in a way to
basically try to ride him in a way that
fans would continue and join but also
interject new things that they hadn't
seen before but the reason why I say
death in the family plays a prominent
role in this particular bit of a story
is because in death in the family The
Joker basically beat Jason Todd to death
and then blew him up and so when Batman
discovered the corpse of Jason Todd that
in turn led him on this rampage where he
almost killed the Joker which led to
Jason Todd being rescued by Talia al
Ghul I think it was resurrected in the
Lazarus pits and then coming back as
this second iteration of the Red Hood
but the fact remains here that with
regards to Bruce Wayne's situation right
here again it's very much a reflection
of that there's a massive explosion in
this brownstone he's taken by the Red
Hood who we know will become the Joker
he's in turn is beat almost half to
death he's almost completely killed and
so again that's what really kind of hits
home with regards to the death and the
family story is because these are
designed to be very similar in terms of
how they unfold now of course with this
being Bruce Wayne
he of course lives he's got to be alive
we've got it we got you know the court
of owls story which you know was a
follow up to all of this stuff but of
course we also end up meeting off where
I guess kind of following up with what
Phillip Kane and Edward nygma himself
now for still it really just kind of
dumps once your information here
essentially saying look I'm not going to
kill my nephew Bruce Wayne it was only a
matter of time before he ever came back
the companies his it's going to be
handed over to him legitimately but even
then there was no reason in killing him
because maybe he would have turned over
maybe he would have come to us maybe he
could have joined what it was that we're
trying to do here well of course nygma
basically uses the facilities abilities
against Phillip Kane
you know Phillip Kane having a metal
plate in his head in everything that
kind of activates this magnetized system
which in turn incapacitates you know
Phillip Kane temporarily allowing Edward
nygma to basically walk away and then
effectively become the Riddler now the
other half of this also deals with the
story of Bruce Wayne becoming Batman and
this is really an origin or an aspect of
the origin that is a timeless thing and
it happens in almost every iteration and
this particular scenario Bruce Wayne
more or less being overwhelmed by
everything that's going on put regards
to Gotham his attempts to try to fight
crime you know he really just kind of
reaches out talks to the ghost of his
father or talks to you know the memory
of his father morale
he kind of harkens back to what his dad
had told him and said hey look the
lifeblood of Gotham runs beneath the
city what is the city tell you what is
this cavern beneath the city tell you
having discovered the Batcave you know
he basically sees that and this is what
inspires Bruce Wayne to become Batman
now it's not just the facts themselves
what inspires Batman here is the notion
of fear and that is the core of the
Batman character Bruce Wayne as Batman
is capable because he scares the living
daylights out of anybody who wants to
commit a crime now the other half of
this is that with Bruce Wayne visiting
Phillip Caine is basically Phillip
revealing that you know yes he's been
giving weapons to the Red Hood gang and
the reason why is because he had
effectively been blackmailed into it all
and so what he ends up doing is
revealing that he's an actual member of
the Red Hood gang proper now listen turn
allows Bruce Wayne to use the
information given to him by Phillip
Caine to in turn conduct his own
investigations try to find a way to
infiltrate all these different guys only
for us to end up finding out that ace
chemical is basically a target for you
know the Red Hood gang now the reason
why this is an important thing and the
reason why this happened is not
arbitrary this all goes back to the
traditional origin of the Joker and the
reason why is because of the fact that
in almost every single iteration every
single origin of the Joker's ever had
it's always led to a conflict between
himself and Batman The Killing Joke
offered the idea that the Joker himself
was not an actual you know main bad guy
he wasn't the one running the show he'd
been tricked into that scenario a fight
ensued or at least he tried to run away
from Batman and fell into a chemical VAT
and ultimately became the Joker with
regards to this story again it turns the
entire scene on his head with Bruce
Wayne showing up here and trying to
confront the Red Hood gang or at least
Red Hood one the guy who is basically
running the show this leads to him
escaping donning his Batman costume
facing off against them and then
instilling fear in these different
members of the Red Hood gang all of
which had basically been blackmailed to
become part of this group so again
drawing a lot of different inspiration
from the different origins of the Joker
more so from The Killing Joke than
anything else but with Batman
overpowering all these other members of
the Red Hood gang and then searching out
Red Hood one himself
what is up happening here is of course
Phillip Kane was caught in the blast
Phillip Kane is effectively killed
Commissioner Gordon encounters Batman
for the very first time and so that
leads into them basically becoming
friends and turn
of Batman confiding in Commissioner
Gordon Commissioner Gordon confiding in
Batman the two of them sharing
information in order to try to make
Gotham a better place but it also leads
to a direct conflict between the Red
Hood and Batman so again this all really
goes back to the idea of The Killing
Joke in the various histories of the
Joker the Joker ultimately falls in or
very least jumps into this vat of
chemicals and then as we know from The
Killing Joke story this in turn modifies
his physical appearance which allows him
to become the Joker sending him on this
path now again this is one of the many
origin stories of the Joker that exists
out there and it's not by any means
designed to be taken as an absolute
instead it's just one of the stories
that are there and just you know we can
kind of take it for what it's worth but
in the new 52 you this basically seems
to be the origin of the Joker proper but
the idea here is it again this leads
directly into another story called Dark
City which goes into Savage City and
completes the zero year storyline then
of course we end up having the war of
yolk and jokes and riddles which will
follow all of this stuff but if you guys
are new here to come as explained and
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you hit the sub button to become part of
the rob port if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
and we're going to fill this in the
playlist for for Batman comics so that
way if you're new you can just kind of
jump in and you can keep up with you as
you go along and basically get caught up
with everything that goes on in Batman
leading into like Dark Knight's metal
and all that kind of good stuff but
anyway guys we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all in it please
[Music]